Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to concoct some absolutely
insane fluid and smoke simulations. A common
property of these simulation programs is that
they subdivide the simulation domain into a grid,
and they compute important quantities like
velocity and pressure in these gridpoints.
Normally, a regular grid looks something
like this, but this crazy new technique
throws away the idea of using this as a grid, and
uses this instead. This is called the Adaptive
Staggered-Tilted grid, an AST grid in
short. So what does that really mean?
The tilted part means that cells can be rotated
by 45 degrees like this. And interestingly,
they typically appear only where needed, I’ll
show you in a moment. The adaptive part means
that the size of the grid cells is
not fixed, and can be all over the
place. And even better, this concept can
be easily generalized to 3D grids as well.
Now, when I first read this paper, two things
came to my mind, one, that is an insane idea,
I kinda like it, and two, it cannot possibly
work! It turns out, only one of these is true.
And I was also wondering, why? Why do all this?
And the answer is because this way, we get
better fluid and smoke simulations. Oh yeah! Let’s
demonstrate it through four beautiful experiments!
Experiment number one. Kármán vortex
streets. We noted that the tilted grid points
appear only where they are needed, and these are
places where there is great deal of vorticity.
Let’s test that. This phenomenon showcases
repeated vortex patterns and the algorithm is hard
at work here. How do we know? Well, of course, we
don’t know that…yet! So let’s look under the hood
together and see what is going on! Oh wow, look at
that! The algorithm knows where the vorticity is,
and as a result, these tilted cells are
flowing through the simulation beautifully.
Experiment number two. Smoke plumes and
porous nets. This technique refines the
grids with these tilted cells in the areas
where there is a great deal of turbulence,
and, wait a second. What is this? The net is
also covered with tilted cells. Why is that?
The reason for this is that the tilted cells not
only cover turbulent regions, but other regions
of interest as well. In this case, it enables us
to capture this narrow flow around the obstacle.
Without this new AST grid, some of these
smoke plumes wouldn’t make it through the net.
Experiment number three. The boat ride. Note that
the surface of the pool is completely covered with
the new tilted cells, making sure that the wake
of the boat is as detailed as it can possibly
be. But in the meantime, the algorithm is not
wasteful, look, the volume itself is free of them.
And now, hold on to your papers
for experiment number four.
Thin water sheets. You can see the final
simulation here, and if we look under the hood,
my goodness, just look at how much work this
algorithm is doing. And what is even better,
it only does so where it is really needed it
doesn’t do any extra work in these regions.
I am so far, very impressed with this technique.
We saw that it does a ton of work for us,
and increases the detail in our simulations, and
helps things flow through where they should really
flow through. Now, with that said, there is only
one question left. What does this cost us? How
much more expensive is this kind of AST grid
simulation than a regular grid? +100 percent
computation time? +50 percent? How much is it
worth to you? Please stop the video and leave a
comment with your guess. I’ll wait. Thank you! The
answer is none of those. It costs almost nothing,
and adds typically an additional 1% of computation
time. And in return for that almost nothing,
we get all of these beautiful fluid and
smoke simulations. What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!